[Music]
welcome everybody to the second webinar
of our t-cell series
t-cell culture fine-tuning your t-cell
research workflow step by step
in the next 35 minutes you will learn
all about the best t-cell culture
products by miltoni biotek
so enjoy
please acknowledge the displayed
disclaimer
so let's begin with a brief company
presentation
miltoni biotech was founded 1989 by
stefan miltoni himself and is the
largest owner managed company in germany
we have two main sites in germany
one in baggage gladbach where the
headquarters are located and one in
tetero where the gmp manufacturing
facility is located
we have subsidiaries in 28 countries and
distribute to additional 73 countries
currently we employ over 3 000 employees
worldwide
our mission is to serve the needs in
life science research and to translate
new scientific findings into clinical
applications
as for the agenda first we will have a
brief look at the biology and function
of t cells as well as at the concept of
workflows and the hallmarks of mac cell
culture
next we will have a look at our
highlight t cell culture products we
start with media and cytokines for t
cell expansion and polarization
then we will learn about t cell
stimulation reagents for polyclonal but
also antigen specific t cell stimulation
and finally we will talk about max gmp
quality grade as ideal tool for tesla
manufacturing in a clinical context
let's start out with a brief
introduction about the biology and
function of t cells
a quick look at t cell biology covers
the basic aspects when talking about t
cell phenotypes and function mostly
surface markers cytokines and
transcription factors come into play as
defining molecules
t cells hereby play as the factors of
the immune system an integral role in
the adaptive immunity
they can be subdivided broadly into
several phenotypically and functionally
distinct subsets such as the helper
cells cytotoxic tequila cells t
regulatory cells as well as the rather
heterogenic group of unconventional t
cells comprising for example natural
killer t cells and gamma delta t cells
t
are the only immune cells that are able
to form a long-lasting immunological
memory that helps to respond faster and
more efficient to already experience
threats
key surface markers that are always
mentioned in regards to t-cells are the
t-cell receptor tcr that recognize
antigens as well as the activating
co-receptors cd3 and cd28
those three surface markers are present
on all t cells
furthermore co-receptors cd4 and cd8 are
the defining markers for t helper cells
and cytotoxic tequila cells respectively
to exert the function as effectors of
the immune system t cells release
cytokines to communicate with the
environment and to cause various effects
such as promoting inflammation
these cytokines include interlocuting 2
interlocking 4 interferon gamma tumor
necrosis factor alpha transforming
growth factor beta and interlocking 10.
t cells are most relevant in both
maintenance of health as well as
fighting diseases
last but not least these properties make
t-cells ideal tools for immunotherapy
where t-cells for example are
genetically modified as car t-cells to
attack cancer specifically
although our best known products are
indeed the microbeads and isolation kits
we are not just a cell separation
company we actually cover the whole
experimental t-cell workflow from cell
separation to cell analysis including
also sample preparation as well as cell
culture
we provide thereby solutions for each
step of your experiment
and today we concentrate on t-cell
culture
well although it may be now easier to
get an overlook of our product world we
thought maybe the best way to arrange
our large t-cell portfolio are distinct
workflows specifically designed for your
experimental needs
thereby we cover as focused workflows
amongst others regulatory t cells car t
cell research gamma delta t cells tumor
infiltrating leukocytes polarization of
t cells antigen and virus specific t
cells and of course activation and
expansion of t cells
with these comprehensive workflows you
can easily choose the products relevant
for your specific field of interest
please keep in mind the diesel portfolio
is growing by the day and the respective
workflow overviews are all work in
progress so check regularly for updates
by the way you may notice throughout the
presentation small yellow buttons paired
with a little click hand symbol just
like the one on the lower right
in the pdf version of this talk you can
access the respective product pages
marketing materials videos and protocols
by simply clicking these buttons as they
are all hyperlinked
your whole workflow from miltoni biotech
means ease of mind
standardization reproducibility and
organization of an experimental workflow
become much more feasible
military biotech a supplier for the
whole t-cell workflow means that all
reagents fulfill the same high quality
criteria and the order process can be
streamlined
thereby harmonizing the steps of an
experiment as well as automation and
upscaling are easily performed
getting all products from miltoni
biotech guarantees smooth procedures and
less errors
since for example our cell separation is
tested for compatibility with our flow
cytometry and our media for
compatibility with our cytokines and so
forth
moreover having miltoni biotech as full
supplier for the whole workflow means
also getting full support for every step
of your experiments thanks to our great
scientific support
moreover a hallmark feature of miltoni
biotex workflow solutions is the
seamless translation from a research
setting into a clinical setting and back
thanks to our max gmp portfolio as well
as cell manufacturing platforms such as
the clinimax prodigy
now let's see what makes max cell
culture products so special
cultivate your
vision when culturing t cells apart from
activation and expansion also
differentiation into different t-cell
subtypes is an important topic
the letter is performed with cytokines
and functional grade antibodies
activation is performed with either
polyclonal stimulation reagents that for
example engage cd3 and cd28 or antigens
specifically using for example our
peptivated peptide pools
expansion culturing is best performed in
special diesel media such as our serum
free tex max medium
in the following slides we will have a
more detailed look at miltoni biotech's
t-cell culture portfolio
of course for cell culture quality is
the main criterium
however what does that mean
let's look at it from the angle of the
challenges a researcher has to face when
performing t-cell culture
reproducibility is essential to
successfully generate results and to
publish
time pressure is thereby a big issue and
repeating failed or non-reproducible
experiments has to be avoided
indeed time is money so time saving goes
along with cost saving another big
challenge
but saving costs means also correct
dosing of reagents without wasting
especially when working for example with
delicate primary cells that is why we
provide max cytokines with a lot
specific activity that allows exact
dosage
cell culture reagents furthermore need
to meet certain regulatory requirements
to be translatable into a clinical
setting
with all that in mind
the max cell culture portfolio indeed
provides best quality
but how do we provide the best quality
with max cell cultural reagents
first
multi-biotech cell culture reagents are
optimized to support complete
experimental workflows without gaps to
allow for consistently high quality
throughout the whole experiment
second we have a strong focus on
standardization since reproducible and
reliable results are the key for success
and third we provide reliable tools for
development of cellular therapies with
our max gmp product line
let's now have a look at our highlight
t-cell products starting with media and
cytokines
of course culture media play for the
cultivation of t-cells a pivotal role
here we offer our serum free tex-mex
t-cell medium
free of animal-derived components it is
available from research grade up to max
gmp grade and ensures optimal diesel
growth activation and expansion
tedious pre-testing of expensive and
rare fetal bovine serum is not needed
and undesired side effects caused by the
serum are eliminated
originally tex-mex was developed for the
clinical grade serum free manufacturing
of human car t cells however tex-max in
research grade is of course also
beneficial for many other t-cell
applications especially the human ones
these include polyclonal t cell
expansion expansion of regulatory t
cells and gamma delta t cells t helper
cell polarization and car t cell
manufacturing
moreover
also for the polarization of mouse t
cells tex max has been proven to yield
superior results when compared to the
standard basal medium
the serum free tex-mex diesel medium
allows for most consistent t cell
cultural results with the max gmp
version and of course our expertise
translation into clinics has never been
easier
for best activation and expansion our
specific t-cell medium tex-mex and our
efficient activation solutions the
t-cell activation and expansion kit and
t-cell transact go hand-in-hand
as you can see on the left graph tex max
outperforms serum free competitors and
rpmi alike in a 14-day human t-cell
culture after activation with the t-cell
activation and expansion kits reaching
over 80-fold expansion without the
addition of zero
on the right side you see
how efficiently tex-mex and transact
combined work in a completely serum free
fully translational cell culture setting
after 14 days of culture human t cells
activated with transact and serum free
tex-mex even outperform a competitor's
classical beat mediated t cell
activation in rpmi with 10 fetal bovine
zero
being thereby more reproducible
convenient and of course translational
a highlight application is hereby the
activation and expansion of human gamma
delta t cells with our tex max medium as
well as our cytokines
as you can see human gamma delta t cells
nicely expand and are kept pure over the
course of 15 days when using tex-mex gmp
medium supplemented with 100
international units per milliliter of
our max gmp grade interleukin-2 and
interlocan-15
as well as 5 micromolar of solendronate
to point out again with tex-max
different quality grades such as
research grade and max gmp grade
everything from basic research in
academia to commercial manufacturing in
pharma industry is covered
tex max media are high quality products
manufactured with superior quality
standards and extensively tested serum
and xeno3
ideal for a seamless translation from
basic research to clinical scale cell
manufacturing
when talking about t cell culture and
media naturally also cytokines and
functional grade antibodies have to be
included
miltoni biotech offers a huge variety of
cytokines and functional grade
antibodies to allow for any kind of t
cell culture conditions from stimulation
to expansion to polarization
this comprehensive overview for example
shows the different t helper cell
subtypes and how they can be polarized
in vitro using our mux cytokines and
functional grade antibodies
it also shows how their respective
phenotypes can be assessed using our max
flow cytometry portfolio
consequently i'd like to point out that
apart from our polarizing cytokines and
functional great antibodies we also
offer flow antibodies for the according
analysis of the different t cell
phenotypes via surface markers cytokines
and transcription factors
thereby our cytokines and analysis tools
are not only limited to t cells but we
offer much more varieties such as for
dendritic cells and nk cells as
indicated on our webpage
please note that we offer many
stimulation reagents and cytokines in
different quality grades namely research
grade premium grade and max gmp grade
according to your needs
let's look deeper into our premium grade
cytokines for t cell culture and cell
culture in general it is important to
use the optimal amount of cytokines
several publications have shown that
cytokine concentrations have of course
an impact on cell phenotype and function
so proper cytokine dosing is essential
for reliable results
cytokine levels in cell culture essays
should be saturated as shown in the
curve on the lower left
yellow and red arrows indicate
insufficient cytokine concentrations
if the essay is not saturated this may
cause fluctuations in cellular responses
the green arrows on the other hand
indicate saturated cytokine levels to
achieve optimal cellular responses
interestingly in the saturated area 100
international units per milliliter and
1000 international units per milliliter
work equally well
in consequence
failure to add the correct amount of
cytokines be it not enough or too much
will either lead to sub-optimal results
or a waste of reagents
moreover cytokines from different
production lots that are dosed only
based on protein weight for example
nanograms per milliliter
result in a high variability in cellular
responses
as the graph right next to the curve
shows results are reproducible when
cytokines are dosed based on activity
units for example international units
per milliliter
so how can you achieve reliable and
constant cytokine levels for your
experiment
the most important factor for correct
cytokine dosing is the specific cytokine
activity
cytokine activities are measured using a
bioassay to determine how potent the
cytokine is in inducing a cellular
response
this specific activity can vary between
production lots because the amount of
properly folded and active cytokines is
not constant
for our premium grade cytokines we test
the cytokine activity for each
production batch and provide the results
in a certificate of analysis
with this values at hand you can
precisely dose your cytokines based on
activity and achieve reproducible cell
culture conditions
in addition at miltoni biois are
calibrated with international reference
substances whenever such such and
standard is available
this means that the reference substance
with known activity is run in the same
essay as our product
this allows to obtain reliable
calibrated cytokine activities
as you can see in the graph in the
middle
all this results in consistently higher
cytokine activity when compared to
non-calibrated competitors
for those working with clinical research
the lot specific activity is of course
also provided for all max gmp cytokines
max gmp cytokines additionally feature
extensive documentation lowest endotoxin
content
and highest purity
ideal for relevant pre-clinical studies
and easy translation into clinics
here is an exemplary overview of our
highlight human premium grade t cell
cytokine products however of course also
many mouse versions are available
all relevant cytokines for tesla
expansion and polarization are available
in research grade premium grade and even
max stream p-grade
also beyond cytokines there is a
multitude of t-cell activation and
stimulation reagents that you can find
on our website and that are worth
looking into
talking about convenience and
consistency the cytobox's mouse are kits
that allow for the easiest polarization
of naive mouse cd4 positive t cells into
th1 th2 and th17 subtypes without
complicated ordering and calculation of
single polarization cocktail components
the cytobox is contained in one
convenient kit everything needed for the
efficient mouse t helper cell
polarization including cytokines and
functional great antibodies
as you can clearly see in the presented
data th1 th2 and th17 cells are
successfully polarized and express their
respective signature cytokines and
transcription factors such as interferon
gamma interlocking 4 il-17 as well as
tibet gutter 3 and dura gamma t
respectively
as you can see below best results are of
course generated with our special t-cell
medium tex-mex
next let's have a look at our
stimulation reagents in particular
we discriminate between two different
t-cell stimulation approaches
polyclonal stimulation that activates t
cells regardless of specificity and
antigen specific stimulation that
activates only t cells of a certain
specificity
the first one is achieved usually via
antibody mediated cd3 cd28 engagement or
via a so-called super antigen
the latter one is achieved where certain
antigens such as peptide pools
let's start with conventional polyclonal
diesel activation and expansion
our classical beat-based expansion
reagents the t-cell activation expansion
kits offer hereby reliable yet flexible
polyclonal t-cell activation
of course specific t-cell activation and
expansion kits for mouse and human
t-cells and t-rex are available
the employed maxi beads can thereby be
flexibly loaded with biotinylated
antibodies of your choice to optimize
activation stimuli
as seen in the graphs both mouse and
human expansion rates surpass very well
100 fold for both cd4 and cd8 positive t
cells
diesel activation expansion kits are not
only consistent in their performance but
also very economically priced especially
when considering the high capacity
packet
please let me also point out that we
have a non-human primate version
available
let's have a closer look at the t
regulatory cell variant of our expansion
kits one of our highlight products
they are available as human and mouse
versions
apart from the high expansion rates in
this example up to 40 fold within 21
days i want to point out that the t-rex
expansion kits guarantee a stable fox p3
expression even during prolonged
expansion periods it is a well-known
problem that t-rex lose foxb3 expression
in culture
as you can see in these dot plots even
after 20 days of expansion frequency of
pogsp3 positive t-rex is very similar to
the starting frequency
again please find the corresponding
application nodes and protocols on our
website
when talking about t-rex culture also
t-rex suppression essays are an
important topic to address
with our t-rex suppression inspector
human we offer an optimized all-in-one
solution to measure human t-rex
oppressive capacities
the kit offers maximum convenience and
easy handling with striking results
again perfectly harmonizing with the
tex-mex medium
just co-cultured t-rex and t-responder
cells activated with the activation
reagent provided by the kit and assess
how your t-rex suppress t-responder cell
proliferation in different ratios
also here please find the corresponding
application node on our website in the t
cell application section
our next polyglonal diesel activation
and expansion reagent is the absolutely
innovative t-cell transact human
it is a polymeric nanometrics that
efficiently and reliably activates
t-cells via cd3 and cd28 engagement as
you can see in the dot plots on the
right displaying strong up regulation of
activation markers cd25 and cd69 in both
cd4 and cd8 positive t sets after
stimulation with transact
as you saw some slides before expansion
rates hereby exceeded 100 volts in the
course of 15 days
as a nanomatrix transect is as
convenient as it gets ready to use easy
volumetric dosage and simple removal by
washing
so no tedious debeating step is
necessary which makes transact
compatible to automated cell
manufacturing systems and minimizes cell
loss
being available also in maxgmp grade
tranzact is the ideal diesel activation
reagent for automated and streamland
translational applications such as car
t-cell manufacturing on the clinimax
prodigy
so transact resolves quite some pain
points right away easy to handle
reliable and consistent in performance
as well as easy to translate into
clinics
so we learned about two different
polyclonal activation reagents the
beat-based t-cell activation and
expansion kits and the nanometrics-based
t-cell transact
both efficiently activate and expand
t-cells but which one to choose when
the t-cell activation and expansion kits
allow for maximum flexibility with the
option to load individually antibodies
of your choice
furthermore distinct mouse human and
non-human primate diesel and t-rec
versions are available
this flexibility is especially
interesting for basic researchers that
need a broader application spectrum
t-cell transact on the other hand is
extremely convenient to use and easy to
translate into clinics but is restricted
to the activations human t cells via cd3
and cd28 engagement
this makes transact especially
interesting for translational
researchers for example in the car
t-cell field but also to basic research
researchers that need less flexibility
but higher convenience
our third and last option for polyclonal
t cell stimulation is cytostem the
non-toxic staphylococcus enterotoxin b
in short seb alternative
cytostem cross-links the t-cells tcr to
the antigen presenting cells mhc
this means as with seb the t cells need
the presence of antigen presenting cells
to be stimulated properly with cytostem
this is best achieved in a pbmc setting
and may serve for example as a
functional control in antigen-specific
t-cell research
since the receptor cross-linking by
cytostem is antibody-mediated
no toxic superantigen like scb is
involved however the efficiency is very
well comparable to seb as you can see in
the dot plots below
so with cytostem no complicated to
handle and dangerous reagent is needed
but we offer a simple to use and
efficient alternative
as pointed out before another way to
activate t cells is the antigen specific
stimulation for example using peptide
pools please remember this works best in
the presence of antigen presenting cells
for example in a pbmc context or in a
co-culture of purified t cells and
antigen presenting cells
hereby the most efficient
antigen-specific stimulation of t-cells
is achieved reliably with our peptivator
peptide pools
these extensive panels of virus tumor
fungi microbiota or autoantigens consist
of 15 mere peptides with an 11 amino
acid overlap covering hereby the
complete sequence of the respective
antigen
the peptide composition ensures the
optimal stimulation of both cd4 positive
and cd8 positive t cells
peptivators are available in different
quality grades as well as in a
convenient 96 well format for high
throughput applications
the different quality grades include
research grade premium grade and max gmp
grade most notably we also added
sarskoff to peptivators to our portfolio
to support your virus specifics research
best
please follow the respective links to
get to the peptivator product pages as
well as to see an informative
sarskrof2peptivator video
please note that we also offer tlr
ligands as well as recombinant proteins
for cell stimulation
in this nice example we stimulated pbmcs
of sarskof2 reactive donors with the
aforementioned sarskoff ii peptivator
peptide pools as indicated a mix of cmv
ebv peptivators was used as positive
control we pre-gated then either on cd4
or cd8 positive t cells nss
154 and tnf alpha expression as well as
cd69 and interferon gamma expression
respectively on the max quant analyzer
16.
as you can see the reactive donors t
cells respond specifically to the
stimulation in comparison to the
negative control with the expression of
the respective activation markers and
cytokines
last but not least an outstanding cell
culture reagent in our portfolio is the
transduction enhancer vector fusing one
after activation you might want to
transduce your t cells depending on your
workflow for example in the context of
card t cell research vector fusion one
is hereby particularly handy this
non-toxic histidine-rich emphatic
peptide enhances efficiency full
antiviral and retroviral transduction
and is compatible with static
transduction and with spin occulation
conveniently no pre-coding is needed
vector fusing one is simply added to the
t-cells and as seen here on the right
thereby boosts drastically transduction
rates
with being available up to max gmp grade
vector fusing one is ideally suited for
translational applications such as car t
cell manufacturing
finally let's discuss our outstanding
mux gene b grade cell culture reagents
maxgmp quality provides the respective
products with all needed certificates
and documentation as well as supplement
information and descriptions to
facilitate ex-vivo processing for cell
manufacturing
gmp is thereby backed up by a certified
quality management system to ensure
highest quality standards
max gmp comprises t cell activation and
expansion reagents cell culture reagents
such as cytokines and media as well as
culture and cryopreservation bags as
part of an end-to-end approach to cell
therapy research with proven performance
throughout the complete manufacturing
process
talking about quality all max gmp media
are manufactured and tested to the
highest quality standards for optimal
performance consistency and safety
this means that their animal component
free
produced in a strictly controlled
environment and undergo extensive qc
testing with provided documentation for
traceability and qualification of raw
materials
as an added bonus i'd like to point out
some highlight t-cell applications that
are covered by our full workflows of
course including maxell culture
so in the following i will present very
briefly five workflows that specifically
benefit from the superior quality of max
t cell culture reagents
of course we have more than those five
t-cell workflows on our web page so
please visit the t-cell application
pages via the links below
let's start with our t cell activation
and expansion workflow which is of a
pivotal importance for so many t cell
applications
thereby reliable and efficient cell
culture results are essential for the
success of the intended downstream
application
in our respective activation expansion
workflow
first t cells of a given subtypes are
isolated with highest purity using our
mux microbeads and isolation kits
then the t-cells are activated and
expanded for example with the t-cell
activation expansion kits or transact
tex-max medium as well as max cytokines
such as il-2 premium grade
lastly the phenotype and activation
status is analyzed using for example
reaffinity antibodies and the maxplant
flow cytometer
next let's have a look at the car t cell
research workflow which is of course
fully translatable into clinics
in the cartesa research workflow first
cd4 positive and cd8 positive t cells
are isolated using our mux microbeads
then the t cells have to be activated
before transduction using transact and
expanded in tex-mex in the presence of
maxcytokines such as il-2 or the
combination of il-7 and il-15
hereby not only highest performance is
essential but also reliability
reproducibility
and the easy translation from a research
setting into a clinical setting which is
typical for car t cell research
in the end but also already during
ongoing manufacturing the phenotype and
functionality of the resulting car t
cells is assessed using our flow
portfolio for example with rear affinity
antibodies the max black cytokine kits
and of course the max point flow
cytometers
another very well culture driven
workflow is the polarization of cd4
positive t helper cells
naive cd4 positivity helper cells are
gently isolated
using our naive t-cell isolation kit
for the polarization into the various
t-helper cell subtypes of course our max
cytokines and tex-max medium are the
best choice
and then again the phenotype and
cytokine secretion can be assessed using
our affinity antibodies the max black
cytokine kit and the max plant flow
cytometers
we also offer a complete portfolio and
workflow for deregulatory cells
we have several t-reg isolation kits to
isolate highly pure human and mouse
t-regulatory cells t-rex are then
cultured in tex-mex and expanded for
example with our t-rex expansion kit
the phenotype and suppressive capacities
can then be assessed using our affinity
antibodies and the t-rex suppression
inspector on the maximum flow cytometer
and lastly we also offer an optimized
workflow for rare antigen-specific
t-cells
first isolate highly pure pbmcs without
density degrading centrifugation
next stimulate the t cells within the
pbmc context antigen specifically in
this case with our sarcophagi peptida
peptide pools
finally analyze the phenotype of the
antigen reactive t cells using our
flowkids at the max quantiflow cytometer
although this was quite an extensive
overview of the t cell culture portfolio
you have to remember just three easy
things first we offer more than just t
cell separation
second we cover the whole t cell
workflow and third we offer a solution
for every pain point
so have all the success with our
innovative and complete t-cell portfolio
as displayed here in this fully featured
overview
again please keep in mind the diesel
portfolio is growing by the day and the
respective workflow overviews are all
work in progress so check regularly for
updates
please follow also the links on the
lower right to access the respective tc
application and product pages as well as
to download our t-cell brochures
talking about more information
of course you can find a variety of
helpful marketing material downloadable
from our web page www.miltonybiotech.com
for t-cell specific applications just
click on the button on the lower right
side
this includes flyers and brochures
webinars and videos protocol and data
sheets customer reports application
notes scientific posters and data sets
and of course you can always directly
reach out to the responsible sales
representative in your area
i hereby end this presentation with this
nice picture of our company campus in
baggage club at night so thank you very
much for your attention and please don't
forget to visit our website
www.miltonybiotech.com
you